hello and welcome to see you playing key
one huh
statistics says I played 11 times Wow I
would have thought like it if I played
this guy ever before and it seems I
definitely have okay playing our boxes
to me and the kings and units I try this
line Queen a5 I quite like the white
this is this line I think is okay DT X
is interesting if I remember correctly I
analyzed this oh my gosh a long time ago
[Music]
yeah it's a peroxy point in a fairly
okay version for black but I have quite
good experience with this kind of
position especially here from this
King's Indian it comes from King's
Indian and often players playing the
King's Indian they don't fare so well
with the maroc see mind he actually six
might be no one have assured before no
isn't Bishop before winning big material
here where's the Queen going nowhere
check okay so here do you do in stuff
right so just a second so let's take
know what is best
I grew up the one I asked me to and
somebody continuous we should see three
isn't doing all that much 95 I just play
Queenie - I thought was if has just have
miracles Queen be black
where's Allen's no okay so I'm back on
to a kind of normal rating 2417
I was a top right back so this is
aligned with d5 I think it's very member
correctly mostly div thanked by black
taking with the pawn I know that it
looks completely normal but back in the
day like 10-15 years ago or even longer
they play Queen a5 a lot and not that
this is bad but I think white has slight
chances here for a little bit and yeah
we saw that it wasn't all that easy I
mean he of course I think this is
getting getting dangerous already yeah
that just doesn't work you played that a
bit too too quickly problem Bishop
before is a somewhat an unusual move
it's not a typical Bishop Square so Jim
check Bishop c3 was even better huh yeah
Queen Queen B to still would have
continued of course so this was better
uh-huh
I wasn't quite why I said better I
thought he can go back and then pour two
before it is actually the same thing
okay this this I also saw and thought it
wasn't clear but it shows that this is
strong that's one yeah this happened in
the game and now the queen is indeed
trapped I mean this is a this is a try
Chaput even if I just play along
I'm a piece of okay thanks for watching